i've been living with my girl for almost
five years when i first met her i had a
beard and i had my own place the sex was
just ridiculously amazing i fell for it
and now i'm in her frame this is her
place i love her i deeply care for her i
work for two years making sure that she
locks his place in i'm trying to get to
a point where it's like i'm the leader i
am the man of the place this is not just
your place this is my place as well so
what you're talking about is regaining
the frame of the relationship and having
her look up to you as the alpha male i
see everything's nicely organized over
the shoulders there it definitely looks
like a woman's kitchen there's cats here
too so if the cat vomits on the floor
who gets that
you don't do that anymore alpha males do
not pick up cat vomit you now have to
lean into your inner [ __ ] and become
something that she's gonna tell you that
she hates she's not gonna like when you
say i'm not picking up the cat vomit you
have two choices you can try to
re-engineer this to try to unfuck this
entire vortex that you've created for
yourself or you can leave and start
fresh with somebody new and not let this
happen again i'm gonna tell you right
now the simplest answer all is say
[ __ ] amount